hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu diesem video von
mir dieses video ist für mich ein sehr
besonderes video und zwar stelle ich
euch meine neuen klamotten vor die am 16
in meinem shop kommen werden das ist der
grund warum wir auch hier die ganze zeit
werbe video eingeblendet wird
weil es einfach währung von meinen
eigenen shop ist wenn meine eigenen
klamotten aber ich würde sagen ich dabei
gar nicht drum rum sondern fangen ja
direkt an und zwar einem wisst ihr ja
dass ich in meinem ersten sechs und am
ersten zwölf neue klamotten in meinem
shop rausbringen und diesmal halt am
ersten sechster werden nicht wie
normalerweise irgendwie fünf toten
kommen sondern 7 und davon fünf normale
merge sachen sagen ich mal und 2
so ein bisschen special sachen in diesem
video werde ich euch zum ersten mal alle
sachen zeigen die wirklich am herzen 6
in den shop kommen werden das heißt ich
würde sagen ich fange an mit den
normalen merge sachen und gegen ende des
videos kommen dann die beiden special
sachen das erste produkt das sich zeigen
möchte ist dieses weiße t-shirt das ist
ein wenig weiter geschnitten wir sehen
doch dass es unten hinten ein wenig
länger geschnitten ist so dass man das
auch unter einen hut
polanski kann und hier vorne haben wir
na ja den print kennt man glaube ich das
ist die erschaffung adams und wir haben
über die köpfe einfach smileys gesetz
die hinten gucken einfach heraus und
hier haben wir das genital eine pizza
gepackt sondern mit so getan hat oder
das vom klebestreifen hier drauf geklebt
worden also deswegen seht ihr hier oben
bei dem design sonst einen klebestreifen
eingeblendet ganz blass das ist auf
jeden fall das erste chance in den shop
kommen wir jetzt schon seid ihr euch
übrigens gefragt habe warum im titel
steht ich bin model
naja ich dachte wenn ich euch die sachen
einfach so zeige wer es war ganz cool so
würde die sachen sehen aber lucy hat
sich gedacht sie stellt euch die sache
nochmal vor weil sie unbedingt germany's
next topmodel werden möchte
also wir bereits gesehen habt so sieht
das ganze stadt ausgetragen wird das ist
wirklich ein bisschen weiter geschnitten
bei der ganzen kollektion diesmal nicht
darauf geachtet dass die sachen mehr
oversize sind also weil ich selber
einfach mittlerweile mit meinen style so
gewachsen bin sag ich mal dass das alles
so ein bisschen weiter tragen ich trage
einfach nur noch xl beispielsweise
deswegen wenn ihr wollt dass es eng
sitzt bestellt euch eine größe kleiner
aber sonst sind die jungs bei hofe die
menschheit mit dem mache ich ja zusammen
meine klamotten die sind auch sexuell
anders wenn jetzt bestellten dann denken
nicht doch nur mal kleider könnte es
auch zurückschicken und ich habe nicht
genug leider bestellt hast du das hier
ist auf jeden fall das erste produkt ein
t shirt mit dem erschaffung adams prince
kommen wir auch nie zum zweiten produkt
uns war es das wieder ein t shirt und
zwar dieses hier das kennt ihr glaube
ich schon die vorne stehen lcr weder
raucher also einfach die vokale
weggelacht das machen ja einige
unternehmen und hier hinten auf der
rückseite ist dann der print rauch lcr
weh so ein bisschen im lcd design
in der hitze haben wir allerdings dann
ein smiley gesprengt dann heraus hier
ist pizza hier sind nur sie knoten also
alles sachen für die ich auf meinem
kanal einfach stehe also ich stehe jetzt
nicht für einen smiley oder alpaka aber
ich habe mit allen sachen irgendwie ein
bisschen was zu tun der aufmerksame
beobachter stelle direkt festhält luca
da ist ein leichter kleiner rutsche dich
hin mit drin das liegt ganz einfach
daran weil dieses shirt quasi bedruckt
mit diesem trend und dann ist es noch
mal stone washed ist man so ein bisschen
an dem stoff ja auch schon und deswegen
kommt dieser leichte rotstich obwohl ich
eigentlich sogar helfen sagt ganz geil
finde ich finde das wird auf jeden fall
mega geil ich bin doch es sitzt ultra
gut aber lucy stellt euch das ganze noch
mal auf dem catwalk hier vor
ein schöner der stelle los es gab immer
gesehen habt dieses shirt hier kommt
auch in den shop also die beiden t
shirts die am ersten sechs reinkommen
kennt ihr schon aber wir machen jetzt
direkt weiter mit einem rudi und zwar
ist dass dieser hier den hatte ich
selber beim fantreffen in berlin schon
an ihr seht auch hier wieder direkt der
ist also der hat da so ein paar
auswaschen stellen und so ich feiere
einfach storage zu übertrieben dadurch
sieht einfach jedes produkt anders aus
also jedes produkt ist einfach ein
unikat
ich hab lucio handschriftlich
geschrieben wir haben das eingescannt
und haben das quasi hier drauf sticken
lassen auf die brust also ganz klein und
simpel und kino auf der rückseite haben
wir gar nichts wir haben aber eine die
ich doch die riesige kapuze die ich je
gesehen habe also das ist wirklich so
ein richtiger schiller und wir feiern
den übertrieben
wir haben die kohle auch noch mal
überarbeitet also die kordel ist jetzt
auch noch mal so ein bisschen dicker
geworden aber trotzdem so zwei schneide
ich sage ich mal
lucy wollte auch den hier unbedingt
anziehen
eine freundin hat es gerade mal gesehen
so sieht ja wo die angezogen aus ich
finde den mega ei von den virgin ist das
auf jeden fall mein lieblings produkt
und ich habe auch vorher schon
beobachten können dass sehr sehr viele
von euch auf dieses produkt unfassbar
geheilt sind und deswegen haben wir
direkt mehr produzieren lassen und
deswegen dauert es auch ein wenig wenn
ihr den direkt am ersten sechs gestellt
ist der bei euch zu hause ankommt
normalerweise ist es unser ziel beim
lukasz ob das ihr das produkt wenn ich
es bestellt und es auf lager ist dass
innerhalb von drei werktagen wenig zu
hause ab was wirklich extrem schnelle
bei dem rudi hier wird jetzt allerdings
vermutlich so ein bis eineinhalb wochen
dauern tut uns wirklich unendlich leid
aber wir dachten wir bestellen direkt
mehr und bevor dann wirklich irgendwie
500 leute ihre sache nach drei tagen
bekommen und alle danach müssen im monat
warten sollen wieder alle dann irgendwie
ein bis eineinhalb wochen warten ich
glaube das ist zu verkraften in der tat
wenn ihr meinen job schon länger kennt
wisst ihr auch dass ich wirklich bei
jedem lounge also immer am ersten sechs
und zwölf kommen so sachen wie shirts
rudi ist keine ahnung was und es kommt
ja mal eine sache die es so bisher in
meinem shop noch nicht gab letztes mal
am ersten zwölf man es beispielsweise
die smiley socken was ist allerdings
diesmal am ersten sechs sind also in
circa einer woche sein werden sind diese
schlüsselanhänger gibt es einmal hier in
schwarz also ihr seht doch schon dass
das von der seite das sieht echt mega
geil aus also das ist nicht einfach so
drauf gegründet das spart sondern man
fühlt dass auch richtig hier als wenn er
seinen sohn 3d druck drauf wäre hier
hinten steht ganz kleine lucia also
wirklich nur minimal und den gibt es auf
einmal in weiß also die könnt ihr euch
auch im shop bestellen und das ist quasi
das produkt was diesmal so das neue
produkt ist da hatte lucie jetzt kein
bock damit irgendwas zu machen weil was
damit kann man ja kein catwalk jetzt
machen also diese beiden
schlüsselanhänger kommen auch in den
shop am ersten sechs jetzt in einer
woche und ich würde sagen wie man auch
direkt weiter mit einem nächsten produkt
und zwar wieder einen rudi louw usd bis
der begriff luther existiert zwar erst
seit einem jahr oder so würde ich sagen
allerdings habe ich 2011 in einen kanal
11 mit deswegen habe ich gedacht ist der
bis 2011 als bei der community quasi
angefangen zu wachsen das ist mein kanal
eröffnet worden und das ist quasi der
gleiche schwarz und weiß und mit so
einem flop druck hier vorne drauf also
das ist wirklich nicht wieder einfach
irgendwie drauf geprägt sind oder so
sondern hier das fühlt man richtig dass
es sondern weicher druck als wenn man
das irgendwie so einen sonnen auf dem
teppich ausgeschnitten hätte und
draufgeklebt hätte ja ich habe an
unterfangen also ich versuchte
mittlerweile echt klasse sachen zu
machen irgendwie mit stick oder mit
diesem flug druck oder irgendwie sowas
das finde ich auf jeden fall ganz cool
mdr moody hier ist auf jeden fall ein
bisschen dünner als der schwarze und er
ist komplett weiß also ich hatte ich
hätte einfach noch keinen richtigen
weißen hut in meinem shop außer der
limitierte pizza wurde damals aber ich
würde sagen ich werde denen die jetzt
auch einfach mal geben dann sollten auch
noch mal kurz anziehen und dann seht ihr
jetzt wieder auf dem catwalk aussieht
hammer nun ist die echte du wirst
germany's next topmodel
heute abend ist ja bei dabei das finale
von germany's next topmodel schon mal
ein ganz kurzer vorgeschmack auf meinen
video morgen
ich bin heute abend beim final und darf
sogar eine kamera mit reinnehmen alle
leute dahin kommen müssen so handy
abgeben kamera abgeben ich darf da drin
glocken also morgen kommt dann auch
richtig witziger blog von meinem ganzen
tag von abends dann halt von james ex
topmodel finale aber das hier ist auf
jeden fall der rudi der in den shop
kommt finde ich auch mega mega geil ganz
ehrlich zu sein ich trag ich lieber
spart von dann würd ich sagen dass der
schatz ist doch noch ein bisschen geiger
ist aber den hier finde ich auf jeden
fall auch ein mega heiß auf dem
kombinieren mit nativ jacke und holt
jetzt gerade jeansjacke gesagt habe
freunde
das waren die fünf produkte die normal
in den shop kommen werden als die
normalen sachen die normal für die
kosten werden als wir sind bei den und
die sind ja so bei an die 50 euro das
der normale preise also wir bereits
gesehen habe wir haben das weiße shirt
mit dem erschaffung adams print drauf
wir haben das etwas dunkleres dort mit
lcd vorne und dem print hinten dann
haben wir den weißen rudi mit lukas
deppisch 2011 damit den schwarzen modi
mit luke schulleiter in der handschrift
und werden die schlüsselanhänger
doch was ihr noch nicht kennt die beiden
special produkte und zwar ist das einmal
eine jeansjacke die habe ich euch
bereits in einem instagram live gezeigt
wir sehen ja auch in hier drin da haben
wir exakt 12 reingepackt sondern die
ganze die beine special sachen heiß und
quasi es devils 2011 das ist jetzt größe
xl die ich trage die ist ein bisschen
rückt am kragen also ihr seht schon dass
es hier so leicht aufgeht und auch hier
auf der seite sind hier so ein paar
offene stellen
das habe ich aber extra so gemacht also
das soll wirklich so ausgewaschen sein
und so geil sein und so ein bisschen
glück weil das nicht so klien und keine
ahnung sondern die soll wirklich locker
sitzen die soll mega mega so distressed
luft seien somit so farbklecksen drauf
hatte ich einfach mega bock drauf und ja
genauso sieht
auf jeden fall von vorne aus also ihr
seht schon da sind so komplexer drauf
wenn ihr seht schon hier die es hier so
ein bisschen mehr ausgewaschen vom
schnitt her habe ich wirklich nach
italien eine kita geschickt die ich sehr
oft an habe und die haben dem schnitt
nachgebaut und wir haben dann falls sie
noch das design verändert also die feier
ich wirklich übertrieben wenn man auf
der rückseite haben wir das erst der bis
2011 so drauf schreiben lassen
also einfach established 2011 das sehen
ja auch schon dass das hier ganz normal
drauf gebrannt ist also das ganz normal
rot und das hier ja keine ahnung das ist
sie das so ja ich vergleiche das immer
mit seinem teppich ausgestellt also man
fühlt schon hier so richtig drüber ihr
kann man nichts fühlen aber hier fühlt
man so die schrift gemerkt auf jeden
fall schon wieder vor ich bin wenn ich
dieses produkt in der hand halte also
das ist einfach so ein produkt davon
gilt es auch nicht viele die sind
limitiert auf ich weiß nicht wie viele
wieder von jetzt genau haben davon gibt
es auf jeden fall nur einige hundert
stück also freuen wenn ihr euch so in
china zu kaufen möchte oder das andere
und was sich gleich noch vorstellen
werde dann sei auf jeden fall schnell
weil das ist erst mal nur so als
testlauf auf das überhaupt gut ankommt
bei euch also ich weiß nicht wie ich
kann ja keiner einfach mal anziehen also
sieht ja jetzt bei mir aus ich natürlich
auch taschen am start
so sind die von vorn heraus von hinten
sieht die sowieso schon dass hier die
selbst denn ich muss ein bisschen runter
geht bei der stadt tief so weit unten
ist so sind die jacke hier auf jeden
fall aus ich feiere die übertrieben
ich bin richtig froh dass wir es jetzt
innerhalb von fünf monaten hingekriegt
haben sollen dinge auf die beine zu
stellen
und ja also nicht diese an habe denke
ich wäre ja die wirklich wie auch im
laden kaufen so mache ich einfach weil
ich auf jeden fall übertrieben
die sache ist allerdings das natürlich
eine jeansjacke ist und die von der
qualität genau so dass wir die square
jeansjacke beispielsweise muss es
natürlich auch mit dem preis missen will
ihr findet die genauen preise im shop
allerdings wie diese checke meine ich
wirklich an die 140 150 euro kosten alle
die normalerweise so merge kaufen denken
jetzt natürlich erst mal was andere
bieten irgendwie hoodie für 50 euro
mache ich ja auch hier in die eu dies
oder t shirts für 30 oder irgendwie so
jetzt kommt sogar mit einer jeansjacke
450 jetzt ist von der qualität das
krasseste was ich je gemacht habe also
wenn ihr bock auf eine jeansjacke habt
und eventuell sogar meine stadtrat oder
so dann würde ich euch auf jeden fall
größere xl empfiehlt die kann man ein
bisschen beitragen da kann man noch ein
rudi drunter anziehen wir haben auch
extra hier an denen an den ärmeln haben
wir so ein knopf dran gemacht also damit
bei mir auf machen kann und vielleicht
mal hoch gehandelt haben so ein bisschen
ich will doch gar nicht so lange aber
nicht wird das video schon wieder 24
minuten lang also guckt euch die
produkte wirklich einfach am ersten
sechs meinem shop an da haben wir auch
noch ein paar mit shorts gemacht wir
haben also ich hab ja kann also ihr seht
doch genau wie bei mir selbst ich bin
193 großer sind dann bin ich auf jeden
fall auch größe xl empfehlen guckt euch
die produkte einfach am herzen 6 und im
shop an das ist auf jeden fall eines der
beiden special produkte die in den shop
kommen werden und das andere produkt
habe ich noch nie gezeigt bis jetzt und
zwar ist es diese jacke hier und man
denkt erst mal ob hey das ist das was
das wissen silber oder so an den ärmeln
ist ganz normal
es ist ein bisschen sonne so eine
dickere sommerjacke da kann man
perfekten t shirt und eine jacke wenn es
ein bisschen kühler ist sage ich mal im
sommer es um die 15 bis 20 grad perfekt
halt irgendwie abends da möchte man
rausgehen möchte nicht nur draußen weil
es eventuell zu kalt wird
pünktlich am start und jetzt denkt man
erst mal das ja so ein bisschen sieht
man das sogar schon ich habe jetzt
leider keinen heftigen blitz am start
oder irgendwas softbox vielleicht dass
sie gerade von meinem fenster drehe
dieses video allerdings würde ich sagen
ich ziehe diese jacke jetzt einfach mal
kurz an erstmal wir haben hier vorne
übrigens an den kordeln so ist der bis
2011 darauf geschrieben rekorde sind
auch ein bisschen dicker also die fallen
zum beispiel ganz geil ich würde sagen
ich ziehe jetzt einfach mal an und sage
dann juli machen wir ein foto von mir
normal mit dem iphone und dann noch ein
foto mit blitz ein paar sekunden später
also dass wir vorne ist ein komplett
normales foto wenn man diese jacke an
hat sind doch dann hat jude ein foto
gemacht wo sie den blitz aktiviert hat
und dann sei das ganze so aus also diese
jacke ist eine reflektierte wenn ihr
also beispielsweise nachts draußen
unterwegs seid und ihr habt diese jacke
an und irgendein auto fährt an euch
vorbei auf 300 metern sieht er einfach
schon warum das spiegelt was zurück dann
fährt er näher an euch vorbei und sieht
einfach komplett geblendet von dieser
reflektive jacket von dieser limited
rief entwickelt also die ist genauso wie
die jeansjacke auch limitiert also falls
wir haben möchtet müsst ihr
wahrscheinlich auch er schnell sein
ich meine gebt euch das so denkt man das
ist eine komplett normale jacke und dann
macht eine antwort mit blitz irgendwie
bei der abenddämmerung foto mit freunden
und man selbst ist halt einfach das
komplette foto wegen der jagd im mega
geil ich wollte schon voll von lange
irgendwas mit reflective machen und alle
machten
smiley reflexiv sowie bei dem roten
jetzt videos gemacht dass aber diese
jacke wirklich komplett effekte vermerk
auf der stoff ist ein bisschen fester
und so weiter und so fort und das
branding ist auch wirklich nur bürger
diese kordeln hier aber dass das ist
krank
das ist einfach eine heftige technik
also diese beiden sachen sind jetzt die
beiden special sachen die am ersten
sechs in meinem shop kommen werden
einerseits die jeansjacke und diese
reflexiv jacke die werden beide denken
so um die 140 euro kosten
es tut mir leid dass die preise so teuer
sind aber das sind einfach krassere
produkte und die dauern einfach länger
zu machen zum beispiel an deren effekte
yakin arbeiten wir seit märz um halben
jahr dran und das dauert auch einfach
länger duffys mehr arbeit rennen das ist
einfach größer und schwieriger zu machen
als jetzt ein stinknormales shirt mit
dem print drauf ich hoffe ihr versteht
mich da ich zwinge natürlich niemandem
irgendetwas zu kaufen
ich selber bin nur ein mensch wenn ich
etwas mache dann will ich es richtig
machen
deswegen meine pizza ein bisschen teurer
dafür war sie größer und qualitativ
besser und hat auch einfach wichtig das
war meine lieblings pizza und genauso
auch bei meinen klamotten und dann
möchte ich lieber ein bisschen mehr zeit
lassen und nicht jede woche ein neues
produkt hause wie es irgendwie laufen
pro nacht oder so überhaupt nichts
dagegen aber es sind halt normale
produkte sondern macht dann halt
irgendwie sowas krasses und lassen ein
bisschen mehr zeit und dann ist es
natürlich auch ein bisschen teurer aber
wie gesagt sind limitiert so wenn ihr
euch nicht kaufen möchte was euch zu
teuer ist dann gibt's natürlich auch
noch die anderen sachen oder kopfrechnen
schlüsselanhänger der kostet wirklich
fast nichts ich bin auf jeden fall mega
froh dass ich euch jetzt endlich alle
sachen sage ich mal zeigen konnte in
einer woche am erste sechster als ich
hier nochmal erste sechste wirklich 15
uhr do kann mir shop.de da kommen die
sachen reinen danke dass sie mich jetzt
so lange hier aushalten konnte
ich dachte mir hey yo ich denen die
videokunst sollte vielleicht zu sieben
minuten erstellen und jedes produkt kurz
vor aber es gibt zu jedem produkt
sondern hintergrundgeschichte manchmal
auch wenn diese mehr schafft von adam
shirt wollte ich zuerst das letzte
abendmahl neben wo alle an diesem tisch
sitzen und dann haben alles quasi sonne
sonst mal die augen anschaut ist wieder
brot und wein essen trinken die
irgendwie cola und
essen halten die pizza oder so aber da
dachten wir dann halt ja da habe ich ja
schon vor monaten fragen machte haye ist
es vielleicht ein bisschen blöd das
letzte abendmahl jetzt eben diesem match
zu nehmen
deswegen haben wir jetzt ja schon von
adams genommen hatten zwischendurch noch
nach hoya noch seinen reiter mit einem
smiley wird quasi ausgestattet und es
gibt zu jedem produkt wirklich ihnen
eine story
deswegen wollte ich einfach unbedingt
dieses video machen ich weiß dass auf
einem kanal normalerweise sind nur
unterhaltung sachen kommen oder man
gaming oder irgendwie ich zum beispiel
noch vor einer woche und hat mit alexa
geredet die mich übelst abgefuckt hat
aber so was finde ich muss auch mal sein
vor allem bei so einem projekt wie
klamotten wo ich jetzt wirklich seit
monaten hinterher hinke also ja freunde
erste sechste ich habe es oft genug
gesagt mir findet link in der
beschreibung ich würde mich freuen wenn
ihr euch ein paar sachen bestellen würde
die können sich auch anprobieren wenn es
euch nicht gefällt könnte es auch
zurückschicken